[Musique]
bonjour Arthur bonjour Patrice merci de
m'avoir vous êtes un des co-fondateurs
de time for Planet on trouve on va
parler et puis vous êtes ici à Yvelines
Business Club c'est que vous allez
rencontrer des chefs d'entreprise ça
fait partie je suppose de votre job
alors tu as une forte planète c'est donc
une société que vous avez monté vous
êtes si associé je crois tout à fait et
ça devient ce que ça veut dire du temps
pour la planète mais expliquez-nous
quand même l'idée est très simple en
fait on est six entrepreneurs on a tous
monté des boîtes dans différents
secteurs depuis 10-15 ans et on n'est
pas des grands écolos à la base on n'est
pas des experts du climat en fait on a
pris conscience assez tardivement de
l'ampleur de l'urgence climatique et
comme plein de gens on s'est dit bah on
aimerait bien participer un peu à ça
mais ce qu'on voit très vite quand on
est en simple citoyen c'est qu'une fois
qu'on a fait pipi sous la douche et
qu'on a acheté une trottinette
regarde tous un peu dans le blanc des
yeux en disant que ça va pas suffire
cette histoire et nous on avait une
conviction c'est que l'entreprise est un
outil absolument formidable pour
transformer nos modes de vie à très
grande échelle et que l'entreprise peut
être une part de la solution donc on
s'est demandé comment on pouvait
imaginer un modèle d'entreprise qui nous
aide à avoir beaucoup d'impact et ce
qu'on a commencé par faire c'est
rencontrer des grands scientifiques Jean
Josel d'autres membres du GIEC en leur
demandant prix Nobel qui est à fait
décidé tout à fait qui est d'ailleurs un
des monsieur qui a permis de trouver le
lien entre les gaz à effet de serre et
le réchauffement climatique quelqu'un
qui a un peu rouler sa bosse sur les
sujets et qui nous a dit mais en fait
aujourd'hui il y a deux angles
principaux il y a un la sobriété donc ça
y est nos ministres mettre des col
roulés on y va doucement et de
l'innovation dans le sens faire
autrement parce que l'innovation peut
nous permettre de transformer de manière
systémique notre économie pour la
décarbonée et là où démarre time for the
planet c'est qu'à chaque fois on nous
remonte le même constat les innovations
dont on a besoin maintenant pour ce
décarboner à grande échelle en fait
elles sont déjà là elles existent
exactement il faut pas attendre des
nouveautés et vous le savez très bien le
sujet c'est qu'elles sont portées par
les avoir d'autres mais il y en a et
beaucoup il y en aura d'autres c'est sûr
mais le sujet c'est que ces innovations
sont souvent portées par des gens qui
sont un profil ingénieur chercheur
scientifiques et c'est pas des
entrepreneurs donc trouver un modèle
économique transformé en entreprise
l'innovation faire en sorte qu'elle se
déploie à grande échelle qu'elle est un
impact qu'elle change nos vies c'est pas
leur métier c'est même bien mettre
allemand l'opposé de leur métier et nous
ça nous a semblé un peu fou parce qu'on
connaissait très bons entrepreneurs qui
justement cherchaient comme nous à
donner un peu plus de sens alors
compétences entrepreneuriale et on s'est
dit bah réunissons ces deux forces
prenons d'un côté des innovations à
impact qui sont capables de changer la
donne et de l'autre de très bons
entrepreneurs qui sont capables de faire
en sorte que ces innovations se
déploient très vite donc c'est ça le
coeur
il faut des fonds
avec tout seul avec nos petits bras nous
on n'est pas on vient pas du monde de la
levée de fonds voilà on a fait des
startups on le fait un peu d'argent mais
on sait pas faire ça et donc on s'est
dit ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse c'est
quelque chose de collect qui permettent
à n'importe qui d'élargir son rayon
d'action pour le climat grâce à son
argent donc n'importe qui peut devenir
associé copropriétaire c'est pas un don
d'accord en investissant à partir d'un
euro voilà et en devenant copropriétaire
son argent permet donc de trouver ses
innovations de les sélectionner de les
financer de recruter les entrepreneurs
mais tous ces associés puisque
aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 100000 nous
aident aussi à trouver des talents pour
les boîtes que l'on lance des clients et
en fait ça accélère vraiment vraiment la
diffusion de ces innovations beaucoup
plus fort que si c'était juste de
l'argent la création c'est qu'elle est
2019 décembre 2019 donc après quatre ans
à peu près un petit cru peut-être avant
le covid
mais vous avez déjà
en mise de fond un capital important une
vingtaine de millions d'euros ouais tout
à fait ce qui commence à faire après on
a encore de la route puisque notre but
c'est 2030 on imagine parce que en fait
ce que vous avez très bien rappelé c'est
qu'on a commencé avec les citoyens donc
au démarrage on a fait notre preuve de
concept sans aller chercher des
institutions capables de nous financer
2030 le plan du gouvernement qui nous a
fait un accord pour une quinzaine de
millions d'euros on commence à avoir des
gros investisseurs pour plusieurs
millions d'euros voir en dizaine de
millions d'euros donc maintenant il va
falloir qu'on réussisse le pari parce
que nous on mise sur l'Open Source on a
un modèle d'entreprise un peu
particulière on va peut-être y revenir
et donc ces gens là on rentre pas dans
les cas c'est quoi alors l'idée c'est de
faire de la licence libre l'Open Source
c'est un peu le terme vulgaire pour dire
que on partage les innovations et on
permet à d'autres de commercialiser
gratuitement ces innovations donc de
lancer leur business à partir de nos
innovations à partir des brevets que
nous on a mais on avait des Bronzés tout
à fait il y a des brevets mais ces
brevets on peut créer une licence de
sucre et une licence libre qu'on
distribue gratuitement et n'importe qui
peut lancer l'innovation partout dans le
monde ça aide à la au déploiement par
contre en échange il y a deux devoirs le
premier c'est de repartager ses propres
améliorations avec l'ensemble des
possédants de la licence ce qui
mutualise la R&D ce qui nous aide à
aller plus vite nous si on se casse la
gueule d'autres réussissent et on peut
repartir à partir de leur suite à eux et
le deuxième truc c'est qu'il doit nous
repartager leur impact en tonnes de CO2
éviter et donc ça c'est important parce
que nous on mutualise non seulement les
tonnes de CO2 de nos boîtes directement
mais aussi les tonnes évitées par toutes
les boîtes qui sont créées grâce à ses
licences et ce qui nous permet d'avoir
beaucoup d'impact pour nos actionnaires
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on les
rémunère c'est intéressant parce que
c'est quand même un tout nouveau
fonctionnement quoi de de du business
des sociétés je pensais à Firefox par
exemple qui a fait ça aussi pour
Internet
et c'est vrai que c'est des schémas que
je sais pas il y a 20 ans je sais pas si
des autres chefs d'entreprise non c'est
sûr aujourd'hui c'est encore compliqué
mais dans l'industrie Elon Musk par
exemple on en parlait en tout à l'heure
sur ces super chargeurs il a décidé de
faire ça parce qu'il s'est dit si je
suis tout seul à équiper les routes du
monde
c'est prêt en 2050 le marché de
l'électrique moi je vais être leader en
2030 et donc il s'est dit bah je vais
jouer collectif je vais le filer gratos
aux autres constructeurs qui vont juste
leur prendre en marque blanche ils vont
équiper les routes avec moi ça va certes
les acc mais moi ça va m'accélérer
encore beaucoup plus puisque le marché
sera porteur avec les 20 millions que
vous avez déjà récolté combien de de
boîte d'innovation vous avez déjà pu
financer à peu près là on a fait 6
premières boîtes c'est vraiment la
preuve de concept de time for the planet
dont certaines ont déjà un an et demi de
financement on voit vraiment d'ailleurs
que le modèle fonctionne parce que ça
les accélère vraiment très très fort
l'objectif c'est d'aller en faire 100 et
on a reçu plus de 1200 dossiers
aujourd'hui les dossiers que vous
recevez
comment vous faites avec les six
associés qui qui
vous faites appel aussi là aussi il y a
des experts dont je suppose alors on a
toujours le même mélange chez time for
the planète c'est tech et intelligence
collective d'accord on met les deux
ensemble et donc là l'intelligence
collective elle se matérialise parce
qu'on appelle des évaluateurs c'est donc
des associés de timephosate qui
choisissent de donner du temps en plus
et donc on les forme et sur une
plateforme en ligne ils vont aller
évaluer nos innovations donc en fonction
de six critères il les note ce qui nous
permet de faire un top tous les
trimestres qui ensuite passe dans un
comité d'experts là c'est le
scientifique donc 14 experts directeur
du CNRS directrice de ligne etc c'est
des gens qui sont vraiment dans le
métier et eux ils reçoivent un top parce
qu'ils vont pas s'amuser à trier 300
innovations en revanche ils reçoivent
entre 5 et 10 par trimestre il se
réunissent une journée il passe du temps
et challenge les porteurs de projet ils
creuse vraiment le sujet et ils doivent
décider par consensus des innovations
qui passent à l'étape d'après ou là on
va valider la réalité économique donc on
va chercher des vraies clients pour ces
innovations et quand on a fait tout ça
seulement à ce moment-là on vote en
assemblée générale donc ça se fait en
ligne sinon c'est imposable avec 100 000
actionnaires et on dit bah voilà on a
cette droite 110
000 un peu plus aujourd'hui donc on
pourrait pas les réunir autour d'un
dîner et leur dire et qui veut même pas
très compliqué les grosses boîtes comme
ça
du digital justement aussi c'est que ça
nous permet de faire voter plein plein
de gens de partout Madame Michu qui a
mis en euros bah elle vote ça lui fait
plaisir voilà
le repas tous les projets que vous avez
fait venus j'ai vu qu'il y avait un des
premiers je pense où on repeint les
toits en blanc
donc le principe c'est que quand une
surface est blanche elle renvoie le
rayonnement solaire et eux ils ont
inventé une peinture à base de coquilles
d'huîtres qui dure 20 ans qui a pas de
pétrochimie et qui renvoie 95 % du
rayonnement solaire donc ce que ça
produit c'est que plutôt qu'avoir un
toit noir qui absorbe le rayonnement
solaire là il y en a une très petite
partie qui passe et donc le bâtiment se
réchauffe beaucoup moins et notamment en
été le delta c'est une quinzaine de
degrés donc vous faites baisser la
température de 15 degrés dans le
bâtiment ce qui limite considérablement
l'utilisation de la clim notamment et
comme la clim utilise des gaz qui sont
pour le coup des milliers de fois plus
réchauffant que le CO2 en fait l'impact
pour la planète est énorme il y a
plusieurs écoles dans le dans la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
il y a les décroissants qui font tout
arrêter et voilà je vais essayer tout à
fait ça mais voilà non faut
décollectionner
plus de cebrité et puis il y a en effet
les tenants ce qu'on appelle les
colombodermismes notamment qui de
l'innovation en disant l'innovation va
peut-être nous sortir de là
vous êtes optimiste vous sur le sur le
fake innovation va pouvoir nous
permettre de gagner ce Paris qui est
quand même compliqué à mener non on est
nuancé je dirais on n'est pas
technoolutionniste on est plutôt dans
une vision où l'innovation fait partie
de l'équation quoi qu'il arrive on ne
pourra pas y arriver sans c'est pas nous
qui le disons c'est le GIEC donc nous on
se réfère au GIEC maintenant ça ne
suffira pas évidemment il va falloir et
de la sobriété et de l'innovation et il
va falloir combiner tout ça parce qu'on
est face à un problème systémique donc
je pense que se dire il y a une solution
miracle qui suffira à tout balayer c'est
un peu ambitieux
on parlait des toits blancs dans les
projets que vous avez vu passer que vous
avez
financé
lesquels par exemple vous ont le plus ou
lequel il y a peut-être plusieurs vous
aurez plus surpris ou scotché si je peux
dire en fait certains projets sont très
simple et en fait ils sont c'est juste
du bon sens qui revient typiquement Yves
parier le navigateur qui a lancé beyond
the sea donc lui ce qui fait c'est qu'il
utilise la traction velik alors c'est un
mot compliqué pour dire qu'en gros il
fait une voile de kitesurf un peu géant
qui va sur les navires porteurs qui
montent en très haute altitude parce
qu'il s'est aperçu qu'en fait on
utilisait considérablement mal le vent
par rapport à ce qu'on savait faire
avant maintenant on sait faire des
choses bien mieux donc on monte en haute
altitude on fait des mouvements un peu
comme des 8 d'un kitesurf enfin vraiment
si on veut faire le mal gamme presque et
ça réduit de plusieurs dizaines de pour
cent la consommation du navire donc ça
c'est piloté par une intelligence
artificielle parce que on va pas mettre
un type qui s'occupe un peu c'est
déployé par l'air comprimé qui pousse la
voile très fort et si un problème
qu'elle tombe à l'eau hop ça la ramène
et paf ça la relance donc c'est très
efficace ça fonctionne déjà sur de la
plaisance sur des navires sur de des
voiles de 50 mètres carrés le but c'est
de monter sur des vols de 3000 mètres
carrés donc là il travaille sur des
partenariats avec CMH CGM etc et c'est
vraiment tout bête quand on y pense mais
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est le
mix entre la lothèque donc vraiment avec
une voile quoi on n'a pas réin mais
l'intelligence artificielle qui vient
ici lui donner une dimension et une
faisabilité sur quelque chose qui
n'était pas possible avant
moi j'aime bien
il réconcilie un peu ce qu'on se disait
avant
là vous allez rencontrer des chefs
d'entreprise en quoi c'est important
je pense que l'entreprise et les chefs
d'entreprise de manière générale il nous
aide justement à définir la direction du
monde clairement l'entreprise elle
définit dans quelle direction se met la
force de travail de l'humanité puisque
les salariés vont travailler pour les
projets d'entreprise qui infinés font le
projet de société je pense que c'est
important que les chefs d'entreprise
prennent aussi des responsabilités par
rapport au fait que nos projets de
société aujourd'hui sont très mal
définis c'est vrai il y a 50 ans on
disait un gamin c'est quoi 2020 tout le
monde nous regardait avec des étoiles
dans les yeux en disant bah les voitures
volantes les gratte-ciels
quand on parlait de l'an 2000 c'était la
révolutions
un peu aux réalités physiques du monde
et là il faut définir le nouveau projet
de société un peu de toute urgence parce
que je pense que si on n'est pas capable
d'avoir un projet de société aujourd'hui
notre projet c'est survivre ça fédère
pas ça emmène pas l'humanité vers
quelque chose et je crois que l'échelle
d'entreprise ont une vraie un vrai
pouvoir pour être capable de participer
à construire ce projet de société qui
peut nous stimuler parce que si l'humain
n'est pas stimulé et que le seul truc
qu'on voit c'est Mad Max survivre dans
un désert on va pas y arriver oui
par exemple dans les innovations qui
qu'on voit les voitures électriques etc
avec des batteries la plupart des
batteries sont fabriquant en Chine mais
tout à fait est-ce que vous faites
attention dans les projets que vous
financez que vous soutenez à ce qu'il
soit je sais pas français mais en tout
cas plutôt européen pour l'instant de
toute façon on en reçoit principalement
en Europe mais honnêtement on n'est pas
trop regardant là-dessus parce que si on
voit vraiment une très bonne innovation
en fait ça la ramène ici ça fait de la
souveraineté typiquement on a une
innovation bien San Francisco une qui
vient d'Inde la structure s'est faite
ici donc en fait l'entrepreneur qu'on a
recruté était français on y fait pas
particulièrement attention sur nous ce
qu'on veut c'est l'impact avant tout
l'efficacité exactement mais évidemment
si on a j'en sais rien la Corée du Nord
qui nous propose je sais pas quoi
réfléchir autrement là vous êtes arrivés
vous peut-être pas un militant écolo à
la base
alors j'ai dit un peu par tout à fait
parce que vous êtes toujours travaillé
dans le digital vous font tout à fait ça
fait une dizaine d'années que moi je
monte des boîtes dans les applications
mobiles les sites internet les
communautés en ligne de manière
succès énorme non j'en ai eu plusieurs
j'en ai eu deux principalement mais en
effet et puis après on a j'ai géré
l'Europe pour thriller qui était un
réseau social américain concurrent
TikTok direct alors là les Chinois ont
gagné pour le coup parce qu'ils ont mis
les moyens
ça existe encore mais alors moi ça fait
quelques années que je suis plus mais il
y avait quand même 100 millions
d'utilisateurs
et donc bon ça marchait bien
un jour enfin jour je sais pas si on dit
un jour enfin vous avez fait une sorte
de burn-out alors le burn out je l'ai
fait en commençant le projet time of the
planet donc au démarrage parce que parce
qu'on bossait vraiment comme des fous on
bossait bénévolement et c'était pas
évident de trouver ses repères dans un
milieu où on est tout le temps sollicité
on nous amène tout le temps des sujets
et puis moi je suis assez boulimique
quand je rentre dans un sujet j'ai
besoin de le comprendre en profondeur
donc j'y passe beaucoup beaucoup de
temps je pense que j'ai mis beaucoup
d'énergie donc ouais ça m'a un peu Mikao
et je réapprends aussi maintenant à être
dans l'équilibre même quand on
s'implique pour une cause qui n'est pas
purement lucrative là aussi il faut
savoir s'écouter quoi mais vous étiez
dit en sortant de ces applications que
vous avez ou de thriller enfin je sais
pas
au fond vous avez une réflexion sur ce
que c'est une boîte quoi une entreprise
est-ce que c'est là pour faire de
l'argent uniquement
je me rappelle d'un truc qui m'avait
interloqué et choqué je crois enfin
quand j'ai découvert la définition d'une
entreprise dans le Code civil français
en fait c'est un organisme qui doit
générer un maximum de profits pour
distribuer un maximum de dividendes à
sélectionner et jour là je me suis dit
mais c'est quoi cette connerie une
entreprise moi j'ai jamais fait ça pour
ça on le fait pour répondre à un
problème de société pour participer à
améliorer le bien commun et donc chacun
amène ce qui peut donc l'employer la
mène du temps l'actionnaire de l'argent
et en fait c'est comme ça que ça marche
une entreprise et je me suis dit mais
mais comment on est arrivé à un
truc aussi dévoyé et j'ai eu envie
d'amener cette réflexion avec mes
associés sur que devrait être
l'entreprise
et donc on sait tous recroisés autour de
cette vision de
voilà et en fait notre conviction c'est
que l'entreprise elle doit être utile
elle doit d'abord brasser de l'utilité
avant de brasser de l'argent avant de
brasser des millions d'abonnés machin ça
on s'en fout ça doit être au service de
l'utilité et donc comment est-ce qu'on
matérialise cette utilité bah nous on a
fait le choix de le faire avec ce qu'on
appelle le dividende climat donc nos
actionnaires viennent pour être
rémunérés en dividende climat c'est à
dire des tonnes de CO2 éviter qu'on leur
distribue annuellement au prorata de
leur part chez Planète donc comme un
actionnaire qui va attendre son
dividende financier nous ils attendent
leur tonnes de CO2 tous les ans ils
disent ben j'espère que mon argent il a
fait il a travaillé au service de
beaucoup de CO2 cette année voilà c'est
vraiment le fonctionnement donc c'est un
autre forme d'enrichissement c'est
complètement complètement mais il le
voit comme ça puisque aujourd'hui ils ne
sont pas venus pour gagner de l'argent
et ils sont plus de 100000 donc ils sont
mais c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
sur l'entreprise parce que maintenant
quand on s'était en effet pas le pas la
définition du Code civil etc pendant
mais quand vous parlez maintenant à des
chefs d'entreprise aujourd'hui
l'idée de l'utilité d'utilité sociale de
l'entreprise elle est elle est
prépondérante ah bah elle sort de plus
en plus et heureusement on se rend bien
compte que en fait on fait face à des
challenges énormes mais que il y a un
moment il va falloir qu'on mette tous
les moyens dont on dispose pour les
résoudre parce que sinon on y sera on
sera tous dans la merde
et l'entreprise et l'entrepreneur il
voit bien que il a un rôle à jouer c'est
évident vous avez quel âge j'ai 29 ans
bientôt 30 et il y a beaucoup de gens de
votre génération qui sont
comme on dit écho
il semblerait mais en fait moi comme je
suis dans l'action toute la journée
mais je pense que en effet il y a
beaucoup de jeunes qui le sont c'est
vrai quand on revient à ces histoires de
projet de société aujourd'hui tout ce
qu'on nous dit c'est à quel horizon
est-ce qu'on va tous crever quoi ça le
débat ça donne pas très envie de
s'impliquer ou de faire des choses ou
enfin je pense que c'est normal que les
gens soient écho anxieux donc là il faut
vraiment qu'on définisse le cap et qu'on
dise on peut aller vers ça la transition
peut nous permettre de vivre dans ce
monde là et je pense qu'on ira si ça a
l'air bien si ça a l'air désirable tant
que ça a l'air nul on n'ira pas le
cerveau humain il est plutôt bien fait
si pour terminer on pourrait dire que
vous êtes ni pessimiste ni optimiste
vous êtes réaliste au fond sur la
situation ouais on peut dire ça alors
après moi
faut agir quoi je pense que l'action
c'est la seule chose qui compte après ça
sert à rien de savoir si on est
optimiste ou pessimiste de mon point de
vue il faut faire des trucs puis on
verra bien à 700 vues merci beaucoup bah
merci à vous au plaisir à bientôt
[Musique]